quelle est la valeur pécuniaire d'une
vie je fais je vous aime
du point de vue juridique c'est une
question à laquelle il y a une réponse
et cette réponse est un chiffre
[Musique]
est ce que nous proposons c'est de créer
un fonds d'indemnisation une somme fixe
pour chaque vie perdue vous voulez
empêcher les victimes d'engager des
poursuites nous voulons nommer un expert
judiciaire pour négocier des accords sur
les sommes attribuées
c'est quelque chose que je fais bien
une contribution dans cette tourmente
pourquoi on touche pas tous la même
indemnité ma fille valait au moins
autant que n'importe quel cols blancs
dans un grand bureau ils ont perdu à
jamais des proches qu'ils à mai et rien
de ce que vos frais ne pourra combler le
vide qu'ils ressentent on veut rien
signé
on peut pas appliquer des règles
différentes selon les clients vous
n'avez pas entendu leur drame
tu dis toujours qu'il vont se manifester
le dernier jour si je me trompe et
le connais c'est certain le membre
vous en avez rencontré en personne pour
tout vous dire oui j'en ai rencontré
et quelles étaient leurs prix
[Musique]
comme vous le savez je m'appelle kenneth
feinberg
je suis l'expert judiciaire qui a été
nommé pour gérer le fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes du 11
septembre on vous a remis un exemplaire
de ces formulaires pour l'estimation
pourquoi on touche pas tous la même
indemnité ouais
il faudrait que les demandeurs
potentiels adhère au minimum à 80% il ya
tout un processus
tu met au point une formule objective et
je distribue des indemnités raisonnable
la plupart des gens ont un esprit
rationnel une fois assis à la table des
négociations ils ont tendance à avoir
des réactions cohérente
ma femme décédée dans l'attentât et à
mon sens votre formule est un outrage à
tous les niveaux
mon mari est un pompier de la ville de
new york
il était toute ma vie
j'ai parlé en verve aujourd'hui trois
enfants savaient pas quoi lui dire
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui ne rentrent pas dans
le cadre qu'on a établi
honnêtement je ne sais pas quoi faire
il va pourtant falloir trouver une
solution
à vous de jouer
[Musique]